I did a video asking you before about
what is the best Thousand watch you got
ripped apart for saying Grand SEO oh I
love Grand SEO well apparently uh
apparently the community someone in the
community thought it it was crazy well
they don't have too many at a thousand
you can get a long of a th so you can
start with an entry-level brand a
fantastic brand like a tutor or a grand
Seiko and so I tell everybody that talks
to me about watches never borrow money
to buy a watch buy a watch at what at
the level you can afford hi Mr Wonderful
here and I am small business does your
company qualify for the employee
retention credit find out at Wonder
trust.com educate yourself with a live
expert at Wonder trust now because the
ERC program is going to end soon